Penny was not specifically being
threatened by Neely when he intervened
and that Neely had not become violent
and had not been threatening anyone in
particular Neely was homeless at the
time of the incident so there is another
witness on the train who said that he
was threatening all of their lives
saying he was going to seriously hurt
them and that she thought they were in
serious danger and that Penny saved
their lives but this is what's happening
in big cities so it's unsurprising to
hear that they've actually issued this
indictment the fact they arrested him in
the first place I have questions about
these police officers I have questions
about
you know where this where this country
goes if this is the case we had that
story that we talked about and we'll get
into more detail with San Francisco's
downtown district being totally
obliterated and I want to show you this
tweet
this is a tweet from Ellen Barkin Ellen
Barkin um I'm not familiar with you know
what her career is I think she's a
writer or something but she just
responded good
so you have people who live in New York
who every day are facing serious threats
of violence as the city is Rife with
crime